on a rien eu le temps de mettre dans le
feu c'est absurde non écoutez attendez
c'est une coutume quand même on se fait
ça à la troisième
truc juste c'est dommage ça me coûte
fumes mais vous revenez bah je
reviendrai avec plaisir pour pour monter
cristaux bah tant qu'à faire pour monter
cristaux et puis là vous vous aurez bien
un petit truc à nous escarpiller bien
sûr une petite démo déjà j'adore avec
mes propres trucs avec vous vous avez
déjà vu une balle de basket dans le feu
non mais non ah elle traverse elle
traverse on peut pas l'empêcher non plus
les gens veulent du chaud les gens
veulent du spectacle et vous êtes pas
les empêcher j'adore quand vous vous en
parler de l'espace
j'ai plus peur vous avez bien raison
vous avez compris